[موسيقى]
تداعيات ازمه التعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل لا تزال مستمره مخلفه وراءها
خلافات كبيره بين الحليفين القويين في
واشنطن وتل ابيب وباتت تهدد مكانه اسرائيل
دوليا واقليميا البيت الابيض يواصل
الطماطل في دعوه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
لزياره امريكا ومقابله الرئيس جو بايدن
الذي يرى ان الاستمرار في هذا الطريق ليس
ممكنا في اسرائيل ويجب التوصل لتسويه
حقيقيه وانهاء الصراع الخاص لبين الطرفين
بضمان حل الدولتين واتباع مسار سلمي يضمن
حقوق الاطراف الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه
ويساهم في استقرار المنطقه غير ان
نتينياهو حمل اشارات واضحه هذه المره
للرئيس بايدن بمنع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
من زياره واشنطن مرتين لاجراء مداوله
امنيه هناك ورفض مع اعضاء حكومته اليمينيه
ليؤكد ان اسرائيل دوله ذات السياده وتتخذ
قراراتها وفقا لاراده شعبها وليس للضغوط
الخارجيه وهو مؤشر كبير على استمرار
الازمه بين الطرفين
وفق مراقبين فان نتنياهو الرافضه لمبدا حل
الدولتين بات شخصا غير مرغوب فيه بالبيت
الابيض في الفتره الاخيره وان الازمه بين
البلدين تعمقت اكثر بعد طرح خطه الاصلاح
القضائي التي خلفت قلقا امريكيا ودوليا
ففي جميع اللقاءات الاسرائيليه الامريكيه
تاخذ تحركات حكومه نتنياهو اليمينيه التي
يمكن ان تحدث تغييرات تنقلب على نظام
الحكم الاولويه القصوى في الحوار
فالخارجيه الاسرائيليه اعدت تقريرا سريا
قبل اسابيع تتحدث فيه عن مكانه اسرائيل
التي تراجعت بسبب الازمه الداخليه وخ طه
تعديل القضاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات